hello readers today let us talk about
drama enter stage right and let us tread
the boards together drama also known as
theatre or plays is a specialized kind
of story that is meant to be performed
if you've ever seen a movie a television
show or a play or if you've ever heard a
play on the radio or through a podcast
you've experienced the magic of the
Dramatic Arts writing a drama is
different than writing a poem or a story
and that means that reading one is
different too so I'm gonna show you part
of a short drama on the Khan Academy
website in order to go through the parts
of a play okay so here we have the title
of the piece my unusual aunt but it's
followed by something you maybe haven't
seen before which is the cast of
characters this tells us who's in the
play a 12 year old named Isabella and
her aunt Yasmin now these are the
characters that actors will be
performing in the drama there may be
other people referenced like for example
in this piece Isabella
refers to her dad being asleep in scene
two but he never shows up on stage a
play is divided into scenes which you
can think of like chapters in a book
scenes are sections of a drama that are
separated by time or location scene one
takes place in the evening outside scene
two takes place at Isabella's house
sometime later how do we know that the
setting and stage directions so this
italic slanty text here in the brackets
tells us where the scene is set in time
and space
it says evening Isabella is walking her
dog Stanley a bat dives down the name
Isabella is in all capital letters to
make sure the actor playing Isabella
notices and from this we know several
things Isabella is in this scene she's
outside she's walking her dog and it's
nighttime
so if this were stage play we'd maybe
see a set that looks like Isabella's
neighborhood she's walking the dogs
maybe we'd see a little bit of sidewalk
or a fire hydrant
there's more italics in this bit and
it's what are called stage directions an
actor wouldn't read this aloud during a
performance instead stage directions
tell the team putting a drama together
what is happening on stage so a bat
dives down that's going to be a puppet
a prop operated by a puppeteer or a
stagehand and then we have this line of
dialogue spoken by Isabella reacting to
the bat look since when do we have bats
in the neighborhood come on Stanley
let's run home so characters have lines
the character name indicates which
character is speaking sometimes you'll
have a stage direction just before a
line of dialogue as we can see in scene
two anthea's main points to a giant
trunk before she talks but the actor
playing her wouldn't say pointing at
giant trunk allowed that's a physical
action the script is asking her to
perform these are the basic components
of a stage play the characters and their
descriptions the way the play is divided
into scenes the stage directions that
tell actors and others what to do and
the lines of dialogue that actors have
to deliver aloud these are the building
blocks of a play and now that you know
that you know just enough to be
dangerous go write up play tell it I
sent you you can learn anything
damn it out